NASA is trying to solve a problem
they're racing to create the next
generation of interplanetary vehicles
you know the next Mars rover and they're
turning to an unlikely source of
inspiration ordinary give me a break I
can't even drive it with a stupid
joystick I love life build robots on the
side as a hobby the goal of the program
is for the nation to participate in our
journey to Mars and so what we do is we
tell the nation a problem that we have
and let them tell us how will they solve
it in 2011 the NASA Centennial challenge
was born NASA put up some money and sent
out a call to robot nerds everywhere
this is our fourth attempt the first
year three of the wheel motors burned up
second year I then had camera problems
where he couldn't find anything the
third year electrical wiring
so it's always something just the way it
is this year
robear and about 20 other robot teams
travel to a football field at Worcester
Polytechnic Institute in Massachusetts
for qualifying round they're competing
for a spot in the finals and a chance to
win a piece of a 1.5 million dollar
prize she's dealing with the important
okay area B starting 3 to the team's
task build a robot that can navigate on
its own across the field
pick up a rock and another object and
then return to where it started in just
30 minutes
it might sound simple but imagine this
field is actually a barren expanse on
Mars and the teens are watching from
Mission Control thousands of miles away
the key point is it's totally autonomous
they cannot do anything to control their
robot
during that period of operation the
robots can't use anything that we take
for granted here on earth so no
earthbound navigation equipment they
can't use any ultrasonic range finders
they can also not use earthbound
compasses specifically it means they
cannot use what everybody uses today
which is GPS oiled the hurdles inspires
and creative solutions it does turn
traction by using the Sun it calculates
the exact position and correct it
perfectly but there's no Sun people like
them were the ones that took us to the
moon if for NASA it means that we have a
different set of thoughts into the
process of solving problems for hard
things like going to Mars yes yes
but robear isn't finished yet he still
has one important sample to pick up
oh whoa
in the end robear didn't come see
commission
team
I'll finish and so did my desire to of
only five robots that made it back with
their sandals in the perfect world the
technologies will be brought to a
mission immediately and used by us but
the world of Robotics is not perfect and
before these robots head to space
they'll have to compete in the next
stage of the contest in September that's
when they'll have to retrieve nine
samples in two hours
something no robot has done in the five
years of the competition